hello everyone i hope you are well
i am because in my opinion
it is always a good day when we get a
new pokemon presents and one just
dropped today
um i feel like i love the presentation
of these and they always throw in a
couple of things they don't expect so i
am very excited to watch this every
single time as somebody's been a pokemon
fan my whole life
um so this is officially pokemon
presents 2022.2.27
let's
go
hello
hello everyone
i'm ishihara from the pokemon company
today february 27th
is the date the pokemon red and pokemon
green games were released in japan
marking the beginning of the i'm sorry
that's terrifying
i assume that that is ar and not like it
like a like a robot
i'm unsettled
in any case congratulations on the
anniversary
of all those fantastic games
pokemon series
maybe it isn't right we've now reached
our 26th year since the birth of pokemon
thanks to the support of all you
trainers around the world
thank you
each and every pin
[Music]
today
we would like to present the latest
updates on a number of games let's do it
so i hope you'll watch to the very end i
will
mr uttanomia please take it away
hello i'm taco tuesday it's pokemon
daddy pokemon company he's hot allow me
to jump straight he's still on the
latest updates with you all
first is an update on pokemon go
also how cool is that wall
what a great idea
[Music]
surely that's live action
it is
oh cool
pokemon that first appeared in the alola
region of the pokemon sun and pokemon
moon games will be appearing in the
world of pokemon go beginning march
awesome
until then alolan executor will be
appearing in pokemon go it's my favorite
he's so long his face doesn't even show
up
just the best
[Music]
now
i'd like to share some news about a few
of our other games okay
it's a cool jacket
this february pokemon masters ex
celebrates its two and a half year
anniversary right now as far as trainers
go there are
over 142 in total that you can team up
with
powerful sink pairs from many regions
have assembled on victory road our
newest feature hey everybody so cute oh
my god victory road not only can you
team up with sigma suit red sigma suit
blue or sigma suit leaf
but you can also receive 5000 gems
starting tomorrow may and latias arrive
with may in a special outfit this sink
pair can turn the field of play into
psychic terrain powering up all
psychic-type sink pairs
skyla and tornadoes also debut with
skyla in a special outfit i'm actually
not into this game but i'm into this
flying zone they're skilled at
supporting flying types and using
interference against opponents
and there's more you'll also be seeing
ryhan and flygon with ryhan in a special
outfit with moves like sandstorm and max
flair they can create several weather
conditions
to celebrate the two and a half year
anniversary of pokemon masters ex
players now have the chance to scout up
to a hundred sink pairs at no cost but
that's not all if you log into the game
after this presentation ends you can
receive you just give it another try i
don't know just subscribe
this campaign begins we have a variety
okay there's a lot of pokemon to jump
into when you're now is the perfect time
you can pick and choose masters
don't miss out
[Music]
cool
pokemon cafe remix the puzzle game where
you mix and match alongside pokemon
introducing delivery didn't play this a
new way to play
heliper will deliver drinks and dishes
to pokemon far away oh my god the art is
so cute at pelipper's destination
you'll have the chance to meet pokemon
that are new to pokemon cafe remix
the first time in pokemon cafe remix
during your deliveries its powerful
skill will be very helpful in the new
puzzle mode coming early 2022. deliver
drinks and dates
you have my friend join your staff
that's success additionally there will
be three events to celebrate pokemon day
the first event is bulbasaur's happy
pokemon day there will be a seven day
special login bonus and on your first
login you can get bulbasaur's limited
time celebratory crown outfit oh my god
there is an increase it's the best thing
i've ever seen
starting now for four days shiny piplup
will have a greatly increased chance of
showing up at your cafe use this
opportunity to have it join your staff
and for the third event you can use an
eleven times express delivery item at no
cost we'll give you the chance to try
out the new delivery feature 11 times
you won't want to miss this
as the second anniversary of the game
approaches this june get ready to
welcome tons of new pokemon to the cafe
have fun playing pokemon cafe remix on
both nintendo switch systems and smart
devices and mobile
pokemon united is a game that i have
played
a walmart that i actually really vibe
though pokemon unite launched last july
lots of pokemon have joined the fray
together unique pokemon like dragonite
aegislash
or greedent
almost like wait she just said aegislash
i've been saying aegislash this whole
time
yeah it's almost like pokemon is one of
the biggest franchises to ever you can
try out any pokemon in standard battles
and quick battles on special days posted
on the official pokemon united website
the biggest
furthermore there is a pokemon day event
happening right pretty sure pokemon's
beginning
correctly the mythical pokemon hoopa
joins the roster during this event
hoopa can warp ally pokemon to other
locations sounds cool use blindsiding
team tactics to get the drop on the
opposing team
using hoopa's unite move turn into hoopa
unbound and go wild
unibeam while the pokemon day event is
going on all players can try out hoopa
clear all special missions and you can
obtain a unite license
all players that log in now will receive
commemorative pokemon day trainer
fashion items don't mind if i do
use this pokemon day event as a chance
to experience the heated battles in
pokemon unite and finally enjoy a
preview of the next pokemon that is
slated to join pokemon unite in the
future
please continue to look forward to more
content in the future in pokemon unite
available on nintendo switch and mobile
devices
next allow me to share some news about
the pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl games
i really enjoyed
uh diamond
as was my choice
i'm gonna get a like mythical pokemon
probably
oh hello cutie
something to do with oak
soon we'll send out oak's letter an item
that will allow you to encounter the
mythical pokemon shaman within pokemon
brilliant diamond and pokemon shining
i wonder if it takes you to a new place
you'll be able to claim this item as a
mystery gift later yesterday this
presentation ends
you can add shaman to your team and
enjoy exploring the cinna region
together interesting it says it takes
approximately two hours next day to
unlock we have some news about the
pokemon legends arceus game
i'm interested
[Music]
i still think he looks so silly
why do my boy
oh canine slash rowlet like that
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
cool
do we have to pay for it or is it a
software update it's free
you'll have to see it
what a weird way to announce an update
it's like announcing a patch
unless it's not i said it's more than
more elaborate than that
oh my
oh i see
we are pleased to announce the daybreak
update for pokemon legends arceus which
will be available to players at no cost
all right keep you owning i'm so tired
we'll begin a new investigation into a
curious phenomenon that is causing mass
outbreaks of pokemon across the his
region
battles together with your ally pokemon
at the training grounds
the daybreak update will be available
later
presentations that's awesome
glad they did that
and so soon and as a pokemon day gift
we'd like to offer you some items that
should come in handy on your adventure
please enter the provided password in
your game to claim this gift
uh
thank you pokemon daddy we appreciate
that one more thing
we are pleased to announce that
production of an online animated series
set in the history region
this series will feature an original
story that concept is anticipated to
launch later in 2022 that looks so good
please wait for future announcements to
learn more
yes i must
what did you think
we hope you all look forward to how
pokemon games will continue to evolve in
the future
we've shared with you today the latest
information about a variety of our games
but to wrap things up we'd like to end
this presentation by sharing one more
video
what is it i would like to say thank you
for tuning in no worries any time thank
you for being so handsome
and good job i apologize
ryan reynolds pops out
okay yeah i'm familiar with game freak
it doesn't really tell us anything
[Music]
[Music]
this is cool
[Music]
it makes your games look sort of bad
when you put them next to live action
they don't look great anyway
bit worse
side
[Music]
pokemon's just so good you know she's so
good
[Music]
and it's come such a long way
beautiful you got that oled
god it looks so nice i should get that
i'm a big fan of this
[Music]
who are these new gentlemen so this is a
whole new pokemon game
oh
this sassy duck
pokemon scarlet
[Music]
and violet
[Music]
i didn't expect that to be part of this
releasing one wide later this year
i figured it would be developed by game
freak i didn't know what it was going to
be
a whole ass new whole ass pokemon game
that's awesome
oh my gosh very exciting you always love
to see it
um
incredible stuff truly i don't know how
they keep doing it yeah they have some
games i'm not interested in but for the
most part i thought that was that was
like really well paced and and fun and
i'm gonna go dive into who these these
new
pokemon are
oh my god
who are you
look at him look at him
oh my god
wow
okay it's the first time we've ever
gravitated towards a pokemon that is not
um fire type immediately but look at it
how could you not you know
wow
oh my gosh um thank you all for watching
i'll see you guys next time bye